[Musica]
prima di cominciare una comunicazione di
servizio dopo il test chi fosse
interessato qua dietro alle quinte c'è
una macchina del tempo ed io se vi
fidate so pilotarla dove vorreste andare
beh io sono un poeta un narratore
teatrale quindi dipendesse da me certe
idee molto chiare in testa che magari e
diventano anche un po della mia attività
io andrei imposti tipo non so la londra
del 1600 a vedere la prima dell'amleto
di shakespeare con regia di shakespeare
e con shakespeare the funk una particina
all'acidità nella parte del fantasma
oppure l'atene del quinto secolo avanti
cristo a vedere la prima dell'edipo re
di sofocle con regia di sofocle o la
firenze del xiv secolo a vedere giovanni
boccaccio che legge e commenta la divina
commedia di dante
c'è l'imbarazzo della scelta o meglio ci
sarebbe l'imbarazzo della scelta se si
trattasse di andare a fare come dire una
gita già andiamo vediamo lo spettacolino
e torniamo a casa
se invece si trattasse di trasferirsi in
pianta stabile per alcuni mesi o da
alcuni anni
io non avrei nessun dubbio e penso che
non dovreste averne neanche voi si va
sicuramente tutti insieme a parigi negli
anni venti del ventesimo secolo
una quantità con presente incredibili
talenti artistici ma cosa tipo di
talenti di geni guarda guarda te chi
c'era
guardate che avremmo potuto incontrare
questo signore qui pablo picasso
salvador dalì tutti sono poi c'è quello
signore che non andava sempre in giro
così
murray è l'autore di questa foto molto
famosa qui assieme ad ali scrittori di
un qualche talento ernest hemingway
francis scott fitzgerald l'autore grande
gatsby
poi c'è lui con la benda james joyce
l'autore dell'incredibile
straordinariamente sperimentale ulisse e
poi c'è questo signore qui ezra pound
due parole su questo signore è un poeta
statunitense scriverà una opera
considerata uno dei capolavori del
ventesimo secolo in poesia e canto sono
116 county dove lui tenta una
sperimentazione folle con la lingua sono
scritti in inglese ma con innesti in
latino greco antico francese cinese
traduceva dal cinese ma entro e poi non
è soltanto un grandissimo artista è
anche una specie di faro di punto di
riferimento per le altre menti geniali
che sono lì con lui
sarà lui a presentare a james joyce
sylvia beach che diventerà la sua
editrice ernest hemingway futuro premio
nobel dirà di pound beh ci siamo
insegnanti a vicenda qualcosa perché io
ho insegnato a lui a tirare di boxe e
lui insegnato a me cosa scrivere o non
scrivere ad allora
era un gran bell ambiente ma fra tutti
quelli che mi premerebbe più di
incontrare beppe ben sarebbe proprio lui
ezra pound ora naturalmente è bello
fantasticare bellissimo fantasticare di
macchine del tempo eccetera ma sappiamo
tutti che le macchine del tempo non
esistono né qui dietro
in nessun altro luogo al mondo e
probabilmente non esisteranno mai è
l'unico modo per avere un rapporto col
passato e studiarlo ora io studiando
quest'epoca straordinarie informando ho
imparato una cosa che non conoscevo mi
hanno lasciato molto perplesso molto
perplesso cioè che ad un certo punto e
più precisamente nel 1925
uno di questi paolo di questi abitatori
del paradiso terrestre chiamiamolo così
se ne è andato via è andato via da
parigi a chi chi ha fatto una cosa del
genere è qui
ezra pound e dove è andato a tre andato
dove è venuto vorrebbe dire è venuto qua
in italia perché ezra pound era un
grande conoscitore della storia era
innamorato del passato ma una cosa lo
ossessionava lo appassionava più di
tutte le altre il rinascimento italiano
e dunque entravano da qui in italia e va
a visitare le città che sono state
protagoniste del rinascimento e che lui
ha citato nei canti o meglio nei primi
16 canti dei cantos gli unici che
esistono in quel momento 1925 e fra
queste città c'è una città che lui non
ha mai visto di persona ma ha citato
quattro volte quattro volte nei canti
dall'ottavo all'undicesimo cioè con una
media di una volta per canto è la città
in cui sono nato io 39 anni fa e in cui
voi adesso vi trovate
cesena
cosa c'è a cesena cosa c'è a cesena
anno di grazia 1454 viene aperta al
pubblico la biblioteca malatestiana è la
prima biblioteca civica del mondo la
prima biblioteca civica del mondo
esistevano altre biblioteche più antiche
ma erano private di monasteri di signori
quella biblioteca aperta al pubblico
ogni biblioteca civica che è oggi sulla
terra a quella biblioteca come antenata
in senso letterale nel senso letterario
nel senso che è nata prima ora cos'è una
biblioteca e un luogo dove si accumula
molta molta cura la cura degli amanuensi
di copiare un codice la cura degli
studiosi degli umanisti di capire
esattamente il significato di un testo
la cura dei custodi ovviamente ma ad un
certo punto a cesena fatto irruzione
qualcosa che aveva molta poca cura la
rivoluzione napoleonica napoleone in
persona è entrato a cesena a cavallo e i
suoi soldati hanno fatto strame della
biblioteca nel senso che hanno tolto
dalla stanza i libri tolto i banchi
squarciato i muri per fare finestre più
grandi in cui passasse più luce più aria
una profanazione
ma negli anni venti del ventesimo secolo
il direttore di allora che si chiamava
manlio torquato dazi ha fatto un'opera
straordinaria di recupero restauro
un'opera di grande grandissima cura
chiuso le finestre moderne fatto
restaurare quelle antiche restaurato e
riportato dentro i banchi e soprattutto
i libri quando arrivai tra pound a
cesena è lui che lo accoglie lui
dimostra la malatestiana come era in
principio com'era 500 anni prima gli fa
una specie di visita guidata di un
quarto d'ora un salto di un quarto d'ora
cinquecento anni indietro nel tempo in
mostra questo ora viaggiano che molti
fra voi siano stati nella parte antica
della biblioteca malatestiana che
ovviamente nel frattempo è stata
ampliata questa parte ora viene chiamata
l'aula dell'udi del nome dell'architetto
sapete tutti che questa foto non rende
giustizia qualcosa di veramente
impressionante trovarsi lì e maggiorante
sembra che da un momento all'altro possa
entrare un umanista del cinquecento
mettersi a studiare e meglio toccato
dati mostra questa cosa è entrata all
uomo innamorato del passato l'uomo che
aveva citato quattro volte cesena senza
neppure averla mai vista ma il colpo di
grazia è un altro ma gli 84 da ti prende
dentro about e dimostra una incisione
sul muro vede signor pound e ci sono
nove lettere incise l uci rti ha di
lucrezia b ora signor pound la mia
ipotesi è che questa sia la firma di
lucrezia borgia altro personaggio
leggendario del rinascimento italiano
cosa era successo gennaio del 1502
lucrezia borgia a 21 anni va da roma a
ferrara per sposare il suo terzo marito
alfonso d'este fatta up a cesena dove
regnava suo fratello cesare borgia
granduca di romagna
entra a cesena dicono le cronache con
una scorta di mille cavalieri seguiti da
150 uniche portano la dote oro gemme
vestì preziose suonano le campane
sparano i cannoni 100 bambini vestiti di
giallo e di porpora i colori araldici
dei borgia le corrono incontro portando
ciascuno un rametto d'ulivo visita la
città è ovviamente visita la biblioteca
malatestiana
il luogo più prezioso della città e
secondo me gli ho trovato dazi lascia la
sua firma come una qualsiasi ragazzina è
sconvolto è veramente affascinato ed la
pound da questa cosa decide di fare un
regalo un regalo alla città di cesena
porta in dono alla mafia stiana un libro
una edizione fuori commercio
limitatissima dei sedici canti che ha
scritto finora scrive di suo pugno in
italiano una dedica nel tempo che il suo
amico mario dazi era bibliotecario ezra
pound portava a questo libro in dono
alla malatestiana in segno di amicizia e
di 65 1925 e p
idra pound e poco sotto nella stessa
pagina con una scrittura leggermente più
minuta ma gli 84 dazi annota l'originale
e fuori commercio in 80 copie non
depositata nei presso la biblioteca
nazionale di parigi né presso quella di
londra ma unicamente presso alla
malatestiana di cesena per l'interesse
dei canti malatestiani mtd ma gli ho
trovato dati scusate non è una grande
fotografia loro l'ho fatta io
però è tra punk ed è un favore a dazi
che il suo libro sia lasciato lì insieme
agli altri insieme ai codici antichi
linee lab arte rinascimentale nell'aula
dell'utri e di questo di fronte a questa
richiesta di un artista così grande
manlio torquato dazi dice no come no
come no
no la biblioteca malatestiana all'aula
del loot venuti deve essere esattamente
com'era 500 anni fa non sono permesse
intrusioni per quanto illustri e un
grande poeta no ma si parla di cesena in
quel poema che però la storia della
poesia
no il nome della perfetta filologia il
nome della cura il nome della dedizione
no è la fine di un'amicizia ed la pavone
meglio torquato dati si iscriveranno per
tutta la vita e nei 100 canti che
scriverà successivamente tra pound
citera cesena altre tre volte e in una
di queste tre volte citera
quell'episodio quel quarto d'ora
favoloso in cui ha visitato la
malatestiana scrivendo nel canto 74
scusate la pronuncia time da un lucrezia
e non the back of the door in scena a
worcester initials jolie caldo nella
malatestiana torquato un razzo che vuol
dire più o meno è venuta madama lucrezia
cioè lucrezia borgia e dietro la porta a
cesena ci sono perlomeno c'erano ancora
le iniziali che bel quarto d'ora in
francese nella malatestiana in italiano
torquato cioè ma gli ho trovato dazi
dove sei in inglese arcaico
insomma se io avessi una macchina del
tempo
andrei la nella parigi del ventesimo
secolo e degli anni 20 anche se in
realtà chi era la
se n'è andato via per rimanere
meravigliato stupefatto attonito davanti
al luogo in cui ci troviamo noi
[Applauso]
se volete vedere il dono che il poeta
fatto a cesena potente ovviamente non è
nell'aula detenuti è in una cassaforte
ma chiunque faccia la richiesta può
vederlo vedere le sue pagine di carta
pregiata gli incipit decorati che sono
diversi ad ogni canto e soprattutto
vedere con i vostri occhi la dedica
commossa di pound e la nota del grande
granitico 34 dazi sarete condotti come
me in una stanza dove in un tavolo
vicino alcuni restauratori si prendono
cura dei testi antichi dei codici
medievali
così li tra le vostre mani il libro di
pound mi piace pensare potrà sentire
l'odore di quei libri udire il frusciare
delle loro pagine di pergamena e sognare
di trovarsi la con loro dove aveva
sperato di essere ammesso penso che ne
sarà felice
[Applauso]